como ésta santiago un gusto saludarte
bueno la verdad que esto no nos toma por
sorpresa porque lo escuchamos en su
momento al actual presidente de donald
trump y renegando bastante de la
democracia y de los procesos
democráticos no yo creo que esto vamos a
ver en qué deriva pero pensándolo en
términos de números es bastante
interesante cómo ha evolucionado la
elección en estos en estos dos días pero
pensamos en términos incluso de voto
popular joe biden superó el récord de
votos de lo que fue incluso este el
número por el que ganó barack obama en
las últimas elecciones a las elecciones
anteriores cuando él asume como
presidente y candidato demócrata se
termina convirtiendo este miércoles en
el candidato más votado de la historia
de eeuu no yo insisto el número el
número de personas que votaron ha sido
impactante eso muestra también la gran
conciencia lo que creo se ha generado en
los eeuu respecto de la política
respecto incluso de esta gran
polarización y división que hoy vemos
tan tan fuertemente arraigadas